one hey youtube right now i am with
Jason I knew that I just know how to
pronounce it so we're going to be
answering a question by angel life 999
who I know as a huge a nerdfighter so
the question is poverty should not be an
issue with the resources available to
humanity today but the effort needs to
become global to true to solve a problem
what specific things can we do to
encourage a commitment to ending poverty
on a worldwide scale so why don't you
take care first of all because that's
absolutely right there's plenty of
resources in the world to go around like
food for example we're tracking what
working on my office hours already and
there's enough food it's actually the
Pinder get access to people but there is
problem that's not what it's the million
future and actual planetary boundaries
are now quite clear to water we can deal
with it and things like water and
regional climate change making it work
about how much how much carbon emission
you can have actually a better land
emotional issues so this hard question
that mysterious or who gets resources is
a big serious question and one of those
examples focus no question says what do
we do about right the Arcturus could you
all
birthdays and camping honest because
we're starting a big campaign in May on
it won't call this but at the moment
obscure justice and resourced and strain
world and we're going to need everybody
on YouTube and everywhere else to get
out there and actually make their case
about why they care about what poor
people are experiencing I'm one can only
process world with enough for all of us
alright cool and again guys I told you I
was here to network with as many people
as possible so now I know the head of a
brown great britain and i'm giving a
business card to ER and new energy
continuing the dialogue and no need to
touch and hopefully great things will
happen so will be great to see we hope
it's catch you later guys and dftba